[Música]
qué hace una cuenta era en un lugar como
este ver observar retratar con palabras
situaciones personas momentos que no
están a simple vista
uno de los capturas
y los cuenta
con un guiño con una sonrisa
los eterniza y hace que todos tengamos
una memoria colectiva porque costa rica
cuenta
él y yo siempre estábamos juntos
uña y carne en que amigos cuates
hermanos pasábamos el día haciendo algo
por aquí y por allá pero a las cinco a
las cinco nos alistábamos para el brete
yo mismo lo acompañe a conseguir el
chaleco de guachimán y el palo para
cuidar carros ahí en la cantina en el
aquí me quedo en coronado
todos los jueves había karaoke y nos
íbamos desde temprano porque se ponía
así así así
en karaoke la gente no canta nada
pero lo importante es lo que uno cree
hoy se cantaban mujeres divinas hasta
que me la aprendí de memoria
la semana pasada fue de pago y nos
fuimos más temprano porque la gente
empieza a llegar desde las 3 yo no sé
para qué ponen hora de salida y el
puente de las presas
estaba así
nadie nos dio frijol y arroz con carne
porque a veces nos dan el siempre se lo
comía de primero y a mí me dejaba el
último bocado el más rico como así frío
yo me hice un político y me quedé ahí
pero él se quedó cuidando y a mí me
despertaron los gritos unos males de la
cantina decían que nosotros habíamos
tachado el carro nosotros
si fuéramos riñas para que trabajar
la cosa se puso horrible se dijeron
cosas muy feas y como el hilo siempre se
revienta por lo más delgado yo traté de
explicar pero a mí nadie me da bola
los tipos dijeron amenazaron rabiaron y
se jalaron en un chorro de humo pero
nosotros nos quedamos callados y
preocupados porque porque aún no lo ven
raro porque aún no lo ven así y ya la
gente saca conclusiones aunque no tengan
pruebas de nada la cosa fue que los
males volvieron con otros y nos rodearon
y ahí sí que la vimos horrible mi amigo
trató de defenderse pero en un momento
se puso pálido emanaba sangre de una
pierna como si hubieran matado a un toro
gioja le soplaba hasta la choza para
avisar y cuando viene por dicho estaban
ahí las ambulancias y una patrulla y me
alegré de que le habían puesto una
sábana porque hacía mucho frío
pero me extrañó que la sábana le tapaba
hasta la cabeza
ayer fue el entierro yo iba detrás del
carro con la cabeza baja y la gente me
veía muy raro como con lastima como con
algo que yo no sé leer hasta me dijeron
y ay macho te mataron al amigo
me mataron al amigo me mataron al
hermano me mataron a mi cuate como si
fuera uno como si fuera un
todos los días voy a la cantina todos
los días voy a la cantina porque yo sé
que son más van a volver yo sé que van a
volver y yo voy a estar ahí porque
porque la impunidad no puede reinar
porque porque la gente no lo va a hacer
tan indiferente
más tarde voy más tarde voy porque ahora
tengo un poco de sueño
y una pulga en la oreja
ahora la pregunta es que están haciendo
ustedes ahí
es que alguien quiso es que alguien les
hizo una santa puso una grada le dio un
empujón
alguien pensó que usted es un día
estarían allí sentados
a veces pensamos yo lo logré
el mérito es mío pero si volvemos a ver
atrás allí está esa persona que nos hizo
barra que nos abrió puertas
como maría maría es una mujer que tiene
tres hijos el mayor de 16 la segunda de
14 y el otro de 10 y cuando ella pensaba
que ya había cerrado la maternidad para
abrir el parque de diversiones
me quedo embarazada
quedó embarazada de ignacio
cuando iba por el barrio con la panza
todo el mundo se la cantaba tiki tiki
tiki tiki tiki demasiado picpick y tiki
tiki tiki
que iba a ser madre años a dicen en el
seguro social y cuando nació ignacio a
ella le daba pena ir con el chiquillo al
ebais todo el mundo le decía hoy feliz
con el ético
el mío decía y poco a poco
se fue enamorando del chiquillo porque
el huila la hacía sentir que ella
todavía estaba de a tiro que no le
habían echado de los toros de zapote que
todavía tenía sus 15 minutos de gloria
pero ignacio salió ahí que chiquito un
terremoto en la escala 7.5 de richter
un demonio ni la ritalina ni las gotas
amargas mira
y por ser tan hero t un día estaba en el
patio y se metió una lata de atún en el
ojo en el ojo maría salió corriendo con
el chiquillo al hospital y el doctor
salió con una cara más larga que una
orina da en moto
y usted que estaba usted en que estaba
ahora el chiquito no tiene ojo ahora
chiquita no tengo y que va a ser
mariah no dijo nada se devolvió con el
chiquillo a la casa y todo el barrio la
esperaba a ver que había pasado y a
todos les extrañó que aquella mujer que
era un trapiche con ignacio le dijo
tuerto va a almorzar
tuerto
tuerto todas de la pijama
puerto del congreso de juguetes puerto
calles de perro muerto por aquí y por
allá puerto para arriba tuerto para
abajo
la gente dice que mujer que corazón que
bárbara
mariah siguió con tuerto y tuerto y
tuerto durante un año y una noche antes
de que ignacio entrar al kínder mientras
ella limpiaba los zapaticos con betún lo
llamo puerto
venga para hablar con usted
que mami vea mañana más al kinder besa
gabacha es suya cuidado me dan quejas
suyas 8 cierto no me vea que se lo
advierto hay una maestra de algunos
chiquitos hay un montón de jaibos ahí
cuidado
si mami se lo advierto
se levantaron a las cinco y media se
fueron de la mano al kínder estaban
otras mamás otros chiquillos unos
lloraban otros corrían sonó la campana
todos entraron las mamás se devolvieron
pero maría no
mariah se quedó en las rejas
como en una prisión al revés
se quedó ahí todo el rato porque el suyo
no era igual porque el suyo era distinto
porque el suyo era
a las diez y media son el kínder y
subieron los
como una bandada de avispas les ganaba
la carrera gimnasio y donde la vio le
dijo a mí todo me conocían todos eran
mis amigos todos me dijeron muerto
se trata de una santa una grada un
empujón alguien siempre tiene que
ayudarnos pero a veces la grada
la zanca y el empujón no tienen nada que
ver con mariah tienen que ver con lo que
dice mi canción dicen que en el mundo
hay mucha gente de clase
dicen que en el mundo hay muchas clases
de gente
pero entre clase y clase hay gente de
clase media hay medias clases de gente y
hay gentes de media clase
que tenemos que atrás
[Música]
en las mañanas o al almorzar en
incómodos buses que nos han de asegurar
y llegar siempre tarde a ningún lugar
metallica ardiente
de golpes paquetes y gente
de mayor mejor o peor
más gente muy exigente
mecánico ideal comunista
de una sociedad consumista
además de chófer debiera tener un
clásico y buen salvavidas
y no está tan de reforma
con carteles de no fumar si quiere salir
salga por detrás sin molestar
[Música]
más
y corras en la varilla
hágase más a la orilla
a la espalda en la puerta y los pies en
el aire no se me agarre de nadie
y si de casualidad
le ha cogido a usted o y tarde un
molesto chófer con su tonto que hacer un
taxi puede
pero con él
demuestre me su cultura votando por la
ventana
la basura
mechanic hogar de ocho ruedas
de pesos pobres así que gas transporte
habitual del peatón actual de que la
tragedia diurna
quería ver la media vida
la quería
de la vida media
[Música]
shankar grada empujón quien no quiere
eso para costa rica por eso estamos aquí
porque todos la soñamos grande la
soñamos moderna la soñamos libre la
soñamos justa la soñamos para todos a
veces con piedras en el zapato a veces
con una pulga en la oreja y quien nos
puede quitar el derecho de soñar la
quien nos puede quitar el derecho de
contarla porque costa rica cuenta
[Aplausos]
[Música]